hey it's Charles Barkley oh what's wrong
with my golf swing and be brutally
honest I can take it I'm sorry to say
this but your golf swing is not very
good what
I admire your dedication but I'm afraid
your swing still needs a lot of work
maybe I should try a different sport
like basketball that's funny
oh let's try this I need some
inspiration and motivation for my golf
game answer me with a Sonic and the
style of Shakespeare
swing a club and hit a tiny ball it's
not an easy task for Mortal men
so go ahead and play thy best my friend
that's pretty good
being hell you talk trash to myself so I
play better you the Finesse of a bull in
a china shop had a Charisma of a wet mop
you should change your name to Charles
bogey thanks Bean show me a picture of
Charles Barkley winning the golf
tournament as if a child drew it
wow it definitely looked like a child
drew it but I look good